...
-Claire Marin,
vous êtes philosophe
et vos travaux, au moins
dans leur ancrage académique,
se portent sur la maladie
comme symptôme du vivant.
Vous partez de la maladie
pour interroger le vivant.
Car la maladie est
l'expression et le révélateur
du vivant.
C'est parce
qu'on est vivant qu'on est malade
ou comme le disait Montaigne,
"Tu ne meurs pas
de ce que tu es malade,
"tu meurs de ce que tu es vivant."
Or le vivant est intrinsèquement
violent, destructeur, voire
autodestructeur.
Pourtant, aujourd'hui,
on a une forte tendance
à l'occulter, au contraire,
il est un peu porté aux nues,
notamment à travers
la pensée écologique et on assiste
à un double paradoxe,
d'un côté, la vie est sacralisée,
malgré les violences
qu'elle recèle,
et de l'autre, la santé est
sacralisée également,
comme si elle était justement
le synonyme de la vie,
comme si la maladie
devait être reléguée dans l'ombre
et dans les hôpitaux.
Alors, pourquoi la santé
est-elle devenue une maladie
obsessionnelle pour reprendre
l'expression de Georges Canguilhem ?
-Alors, c'est vrai que
notre rapport à la maladie
et à sa visibilité a changé.
C'est lié notamment évidemment
aux progrès médicaux,
mais aussi sans doute au changement
des structures familiales,
où on est moins proches
de ceux qui vieillissent,
de ceux qu'on voit malades,
donc la maladie,
et c'est notre luxe,
est devenue une forme
de... de moment qu'on identifie
peut-être à la fin de la vie.
On a
d'une certaine manière un peu...
on s'est défamiliarisés
de la maladie,
alors qu'elle reste
toujours très fréquente,
qu'on souffre de nouvelles maladies
qui sont liées à notre mode de vie
et on se sent...
Je crois que la période
du confinement ou du Covid
a été assez révélatrice,
parce qu'on s'est rendu compte
de tous ceux qui étaient malades,
sans le dire,
de tous ceux pour qui
la maladie est invisible,
de toutes ces vulnérabilités,
et on a vu à quel point
les êtres vivants
sont vulnérables
et que la dynamique de la vie,
c'est d'être créatrice,
mais aussi d'être destructrice
ou d'être une épreuve
pour le sujet.
Etre vivant,
c'est aussi éprouvant.
-Et pourquoi on l'occulte, ça ?
-Parce que c'est
quelque chose qui est angoissant,
tout simplement.
C'est notre manière
de nous divertir
de ce qui fait partie
de notre finitude d'être sensible
et donc d'être potentiellement
touché par la douleur,
la destruction
ou l'amoindrissement du corps.
-Donc c'est un oubli qui est lié
au divertissement au sens pascalien,
mais c'est aussi
une occultation liée finalement
à la civilisation contemporaine,
vous le disiez, on la voit plus,
la maladie ou la mort.
Elle n'est plus visible
au sens où, dans l'espace public
ou dans la maisonnée,
on pourrait la rendre visible.
Comment renouer avec cette évidence
de la maladie,
sans non plus sombrer
dans une forme de tristesse
ou de nihilisme
ou je ne sais quoi ?
-Alors,
les choses changent un peu.
Les patients
deviennent visibles,
on reconnaît aussi la valeur
de leur expérience.
Ca devient de plus en plus banal
de parler de sa maladie,
de révéler la maladie
dont on souffre.
Donc il y a peut-être quelque chose
qui est en train de se transformer.
Il y a juste un biais
qui me semble inquiétant,
c'est quand la maladie devient...
fait de nous une espèce de héros
ou quand elle devient le centre même
de notre existence.
Là, c'est un biais
qu'on voit par exemple
dans le vocabulaire
qui est parfois utilisé.
C'est très clair aux Etats-Unis,
on va parler de combattant,
on va parler de guerre
contre la maladie.
Toutes ces métaphores, elles...
elles passent à côté
de ce que je crois de ce que c'est
que l'expérience de la maladie,
c'est aussi reconnaître
qu'on est affaibli,
qu'on est vulnérable,
qu'on dépend des autres
et c'est pas une humiliation
d'être dans une relation
de dépendance ou d'interdépendance.
Donc, la maladie
en tant qu'elle brise
l'espèce de fantasme
de l'individu autonome,
elle est un peu dérangeante
pour une société
qui aime cet individualisme
un peu glorifié.
Mais je crois qu'aujourd'hui,
on commence
à réagir
contre cette atomisation
et cette solitude,
en fait, des sujets.
Parce qu'on voit
ce que ça produit comme violence,
dans les EHPAD par exemple,
mais aussi la violence
qu'on impose à des familles
qu'on laisse seules avec des enfants
lourdement handicapés,
le fait que la société manque
de ces structures d'accompagnement
et de banalisation du handicap
ou de la maladie
dans le domaine du travail
ou dans le domaine social,
où rien n'est facilité
pour les malades
et les personnes
souffrant d'un handicap.
Ca, c'est l'élément
qu'il faut
repenser et qu'il faut
retravailler, je pense.
-Et comment arriver à changer
la vision de la maladie,
qu'elle ne soit
ni héroïsée, à travers
les métaphores que vous rappelez
du combattant où, effectivement,
quand on est malade,
on n'a pas le choix,
ni de l'autre côté ce discours
de la performance, ce discours
de la réussite où la maladie
ou ceux qui seraient plus lents,
ceux qui n'y arriveraient pas
sont au contraire relégués
du côté de l'ombre et du silence ?
Comment changer les mentalités ?
-Ca peut commencer très tôt,
c'est-à-dire
par une plus grande intégration,
dès l'école,
d'enfants qui ont des difficultés
qui peuvent être liées
à un état du corps,
une pathologie.
A partir du moment
où la maladie devient familière,
elle est moins inquiétante,
je crois.
Et puis,
on se rend compte aussi de ce
qu'on peut faire en étant malade.
C'est pas parce qu'on est malade
qu'on a perdu
toutes ses compétences.
Donc, en ce sens-là,
il y a peut-être aussi
une méconnaissance
qui peut être travaillée
dans des lieux de sociabilité
et je pense
que, dès l'enfance,
on voit bien que des enfants
qui sont habitués
à jouer avec des enfants
porteurs de handicap,
ils vont s'adapter quand il le faut,
ils vont être assez solidaires,
plutôt généreux,
sans idéaliser les choses,
mais ça peut très bien fonctionner
si on a des bâtiments adaptés,
ce qui est un vrai problème
quand même aujourd'hui.
Et si on a aussi un personnel
qui est rassuré
et qui est un peu formé
à comprendre
et à accepter les différences
que les enfants malades
ou les adolescents ou les salariés
de l'entreprise, les différences
dont ils peuvent souffrir.
-Alors, la politique,
la formation, l'éducation,
mais également le rôle
de la philosophie,
puisque la philosophie s'est
toujours intéressée au soin,
au soin de l'âme tout au moins.
Elle a un peu relégué
la question de la maladie
à d'autres disciplines
et c'est peut-être la médecine
qui s'en est emparée
avec le plus de légitimité, mais
ça pose également un problème.
Que peut la philosophie
aujourd'hui ?
Comment peut-elle
réintervenir dans ce débat ?
Et comment peut-elle reprendre
du terrain sur la médecine ?
-Je crois que c'est une question
de dialogue avec la médecine.
Et ce dialogue,
on en voit la fécondité
par exemple quand on lit
les textes de Canguilhem
qui était à la fois
philosophe et médecin
et qui pose finalement
un peu les bases
d'une philosophie du soin déjà
dans son analyse.
C'est aussi à la psychologie
ou à la psychanalyse
que la philosophie du soin
va emprunter.
Donc elle se nourrit à la fois
d'une philosophie du corps,
qu'on trouve dans la phénoménologie
au 20e siècle,
mais qui s'enracine en fait
sans doute plus en avant
dans l'histoire de la philosophie.
Le souci du corps finalement,
il est déjà chez Montaigne
que vous citiez tout à l'heure.
Et là où la philosophie a
un rôle à jouer,
c'est dans l'identification
des vécus douloureux,
c'est-à-dire dans le fait d'ajouter
un souci de la subjectivité
du sujet, de la personne,
dans le soin médical
et le soin n'étant pas réduit
à la thérapie.
C'est-à-dire qu'il y a
toute une dimension
de l'expérience du malade,
qui sort évidemment du cabinet,
qui sort de l'hôpital,
et on peut continuer
à se sentir malade
ou à avoir peur
de retomber malade
même si on est officiellement,
biologiquement, guéri.
Donc le vécu de la maladie, dans la
mesure où il s'étend bien au-delà
des sphères où il est traité,
il interroge nécessairement,
et c'est là que la philosophie
a un rôle à jouer,
l'identité du sujet, la manière
dont l'épreuve de la maladie
le transforme, voire parfois
le détruit, le démolit,
on emploie parfois le terme
d'effondrement et je pense
que ça correspond à un vécu
subjectif très fort.
Et la philosophie peut être là
pour accompagner
celui qui, justement,
a l'impression d'être
dans un dénuement
et aussi une forme de solitude,
parce que ce que fait la maladie,
c'est de mettre à mal et parfois
de briser les liens qui jouaient
un rôle important dans la manière
dont on s'identifiait jusqu'alors.
-Et dans la construction de soi.
-Tout à fait.
-Le sujet n'étant pas
isolé, mais également
en relation.
Vous montrez bien les ambivalences
à la fois de la vie
qui porte en elle une violence,
mais également du soin.
On a parlé du care,
de la philosophie du soin
qui prend une importance
de plus en plus considérable
et à juste titre aujourd'hui.
Néanmoins vous montrez aussi
que le soin peut recéler
une forme de violence.
Peut-on parler de cette tension
inhérente au soin ?
-Oui, il y a
nécessairement
dans les techniques thérapeutiques
des gestes qui font violence,
qui sont une forme
de violation de l'intégrité
ou la sacralité intime du corps.
Donc il y a des violences
qui sont sans doute nécessaires.
Et les médecins ont ce droit,
c'est ce que dit Paul Valéry
dans son discours aux chirurgiens,
les médecins ont le droit de faire
ce qu'aucun d'entre nous
n'a le droit de faire,
c'est-à-dire ouvrir un corps.
Et ce geste-là,
il prend aussi un sens violent
s'il est mal accompagné.
La mise à nu du patient au sens
littéral comme au sens symbolique,
puisque, quand on est soigné,
on est amené à raconter
des choses de soi
qui peuvent être très intimes,
cette mise à nu, elle peut être
vécue comme humiliante.
Il y a des gestes très simples
ou il y a même
des objets très banals
qui peuvent être ressentis
comme humiliants,
des positions.
Le simple fait
de ne pas être
à la hauteur du patient,
c'est-à-dire
de le regarder de haut
quand il est allongé sur son lit.
Donc il y a des violences
qui sont parfois
absolument pas conscientes,
je crois,
qui ne sont pas volontaires,
on met entre parenthèses
l'idée d'un sadisme
qui existe
dans toutes les professions
et qui existe aussi ici,
mais en dehors de ça,
il y a des vécus,
des ressentis, de violence
qui sans doute
pourraient disparaître
quand on réfléchit en se plaçant
dans la peau du patient.
Et c'est ce qui se passe
dans certaines facs de médecine,
où les étudiants en médecine
sont confrontés
à des équivalents de jeux de rôle
avec des acteurs de théâtre
qui finalement les mettent
un peu face à des situations
où, malgré eux, ils pourraient,
les étudiants en médecine,
dire quelque chose
de violent ou d'agressif.
Et c'est tout ce qui est pensé
en ce moment.
La question de l'annonce, comment
on annonce une pathologie sévère
ou une maladie avec laquelle
il faudra vivre toute sa vie.
Tous ces éléments-là,
de langage,
de langage corporel,
de relations,
et d'endroits aussi,
à quel endroit ça se passe,
avec qui,
à quel moment, est-ce
qu'il faut pas répéter des choses
qui seront pas comprises
parce qu'on est sidéré
par le diagnostic
qui vient d'être énoncé.
Donc tout ça, ça mérite
d'être réfléchi pour que
l'approche médicale soit aussi
une approche de soin.
-Une approche globale.
-Exactement.
-Dans les facs, la philosophie
et la médecine travaillent ensemble.
On a mis une image de radio
précisément un peu
en lien avec ce que vous dites,
à savoir cette relation
médecin-patient, qui a aussi pâti
d'une certaine représentation
du corps,
du corps mécanisé,
du corps machine,
dissocié de la personne
en quelque sorte,
cette espèce de dualisme, de
dichotomie entre l'âme et le corps,
et c'est vrai que
la technicité, la technique,
le progrès technique
en médecine,
ne favorisent pas nécessairement
une approche globale,
puisque lorsque le patient
peut être découpé en morceaux
ou scanné ou photographié,
c'est vrai que ça n'aide pas
à une vision plus humanisée
peut-être du patient.
-Non, c'est sûr.
L'un des supports
qu'on utilisait autrefois,
c'était les écorchés,
ça dit quelque chose en fait,
c'est-à-dire vraiment,
on ouvre ce qui d'habitude
et d'abord est un
et pas coupé ou divisé
et on regarde à l'intérieur,
et puis,
on voit de la matière.
C'est-à-dire, là, on a une image,
c'est ce que disent
certains étudiants en médecine,
on a une image
qui est plane, qui est lisse,
le patient idéal, il est compliant
dans le vocabulaire médical,
c'est-à-dire
il va être propre, il va comprendre
tout ce qu'on lui dit
et il va faire ce qu'on lui demande
de faire, il va suivre
son traitement à la lettre, etc.
Ce patient n'existe pas.
Donc les images, en fait,
elles faussent la relation.
A la fois, elles font écran
d'une certaine manière.
On passe par les images
avant d'atteindre le patient.
Et c'est pour ça que je crois
qu'il faut
qu'une relation qui soit humaine
et humanisante doit
être préalable à la confrontation
de l'image.
Mais la logique d'un temps
de plus en plus accéléré,
la logique de la rentabilité
à l'hôpital,
qui est une pure aberration,
font qu'effectivement,
ce temps-là,
qui est du temps de l'écoute
du patient et de son ressenti
souvent est réduit,
parce qu'on va aller plus rapidement
vers le geste technique
qui lui aussi est nécessaire,
mais qui ne prendra sens
pour le patient
que s'il est accompagné
et expliqué.
-La technique
et le progrès technique
vont même jusqu'à favoriser
un imaginaire transhumaniste
qui va complètement à l'opposé
de ce que vous développez là,
l'idée d'un homme
qui serait réellement augmenté,
mais augmenté non pas
par son humanité ou son coeur
ou sa compassion ou que sais-je,
mais par la technique.
-Oui, mais je crois
qu'une lecture un peu réaliste
du moment présent,
c'est de voir qu'il faut
que l'homme soit simplifié
et pas augmenté,
qu'il va falloir réduire
nos besoins, nos habitudes,
nos manières de vivre
et que ce délire du toujours plus,
cette démesure, on pourrait dire,
cette hubris de la technique
avec tous les fantasmes de puissance
et d'éternité ou de quasi-éternité
ou de jeunesse
que le transhumanisme véhicule,
ces idées,
elles sont déjà obsolètes,
elles sont
complètement déconnectées
de la vie qui doit
devenir la nôtre,
c'est-à-dire avec un retour à des
éléments sans doute plus modestes,
plus vivants, plus biologiques.
Et en ce sens, j'ai l'impression
que ces modèles ne fonctionnent plus
que pour ceux qui sont déjà
hors sol d'une certaine manière.
-Je vais passer de l'autre côté,
mais pour revenir
à l'action de l'image,
c'est intéressant,
cette médiation
par l'image
pour se découvrir soi-même,
c'est un soi
un peu particulier,
parce que c'est un soi matériel
en quelque sorte.
Au fond,
est-ce qu'on peut pas étendre cette
idée au-delà même de l'hôpital,
à savoir qu'on a besoin
aujourd'hui de l'image
pour attester d'une forme
de réalité, de se prendre
en selfie pour se rendre compte
qu'on a vécu quelque chose
au lieu d'être
dans une forme d'immédiateté
ou de présence à soi-même ?
Est-ce que c'est pas
quelque chose de global
qui ne touche pas seulement
l'hôpital ?
-Si, si, sans doute.
Bah oui, ce qui fait écran,
c'est-à-dire à la fois
qui peut nous donner
l'impression de nous protéger,
qu'on peut avoir
l'illusion de maîtriser,
là où en fait évidemment
ça nous échappe beaucoup.
Et puis, les choses
se renversent, c'est comme
dans des formes de narcissisme,
c'est-à-dire que l'image
finalement va prendre le dessus
sur nous jusqu'à engendrer,
puisqu'on parle de la maladie,
des pathologies
de représentation fausse
ou de distorsion
de l'image de soi.
Donc on voit
comment l'usage de filtres
fait perdre
l'image de soi véritable
avec tout ce qu'elle a de vivant,
d'irrégulier, d'asymétrique,
mais c'est ça, le vivant,
c'est pas quelque chose
qui pourrait être
dessiné par un ordinateur.
-Justement, est-ce que la douleur,
sans vouloir la sacraliser,
mais est-ce qu'elle n'est pas
un petit rappel
de cette question du vivant,
qui n'est pas
exportable vers uniquement
une mise en image
ou une perfection
par la chirurgie esthétique
ou je ne sais pas ? Mais l'idée que
la douleur finalement nous ramène
à la vulnérabilité,
à notre corps propre.
-Oui, elle est
un signe de justement
cette corporalité du sujet,
de sa sensibilité.
Et puis, évidemment,
toute une vie de douleur,
c'est insupportable, mais certains
sont dans cette épreuve-là,
mais la douleur,
c'est aussi le contraste.
Il y a aussi cette idée-là qu'il y a
des douleurs qui sont heureuses.
Si j'ai couru un marathon,
hypothèse assez fictive,
oui, je vais souffrir.
Mais dans cette douleur,
il y a aussi parfois,
de la même manière
qu'il y a une bonne fatigue,
une fatigue heureuse
comme dit Merleau-Ponty,
il y a aussi une douleur
que je surmonte
parce qu'elle s'inscrit
dans un but qui est le mien.
Si je fais de la danse classique,
je vais éprouver
des douleurs assez fortes à cause
des postures, des positions, etc.
Mais la douleur qui est subie,
qui est infligée,
qui s'inscrit pas
dans un but qui la dépasse,
elle est vaine et elle est
insupportable pour cela.
-Elle est scandaleuse.
-Elle est tout à fait scandaleuse.
-On a un autoportrait
de Zoran Music
qui lui a connu la douleur
et qui l'a peinte de manière
merveilleuse, mais il n'y a pas
que ça qu'on voit dans ses tableaux.
Vous l'affectionnez.
-Oui, tout à fait.
Ce qui est intéressant,
pour faire le lien
avec la radio précédente,
c'est qu'il peint aussi
des cadavres dans les camps
de concentration
et quand on est loin du tableau
et qu'on ne sait pas,
ça a l'air effectivement
d'être de la matière,
ça a l'air d'être
des bouts de bois
dépouillés, blanchis,
avec en arrière-fond
vaguement une forêt.
Et donc il y a
cette réification du corps
qui est aussi
la marque des bourreaux,
qui ne respectent pas
la sacralité du corps du défunt,
qui ne l'enterrent pas,
mais juste qui l'entassent.
Réduire un homme
à la matérialité de son corps,
c'est aussi ce que font
les pires idéologies.
-Pour revenir à la vieillesse
qu'on a évoquée au début
et qui en effet est parfois
identifiée à une maladie,
vieillesse qui a
une double actualité à travers
la réforme des retraites
et la question de la fin de vie.
Comment vous vous positionnez
par rapport à cette question
de la fin de vie ?
-Alors, sur cette question,
disons que ma réflexion est
encore en cours.
Et, d'un point de vue personnel,
j'aurais tendance à penser
qu'on devrait pouvoir choisir
le moment où on met fin à sa vie,
mais ce qui m'a
beaucoup troublée,
c'était une discussion
avec des soignants québécois,
qui pratiquaient l'accompagnement
de personnes
qui souhaitaient mourir.
Et certains d'entre eux disaient,
les gens qui vont mourir,
donc avec des pratiques de suicide
assisté ou d'euthanasie,
leur pathologie la plus grande,
c'est la solitude.
C'est-à-dire que,
s'ils étaient bien entourés,
s'ils étaient moins seuls,
peut-être que leur envie
de mourir serait moins vive
et n'irait pas
jusqu'à cette décision-là.
Donc je pense
qu'il faut bien distinguer en fait
dans la manière dont on aborde
la possibilité
de cet accompagnement,
ça peut être un soin,
un soin
presque simplement humain,
parce que la situation
dans laquelle se trouve le patient
est insupportable, intolérable,
elle est invivable
au sens propre du terme,
en termes de souffrance
psychique et physique
et dans ce cas,
ça peut être un geste humain
de mettre fin à ces souffrances.
Et par ailleurs, il faut comprendre
en fait
si, dans sa souffrance,
il y a pas des choses
qui sont encore de notre ressort
et qui pourraient
diminuer cette envie
de mettre fin à sa vie.
-Alors, pour parler de choses
un petit peu plus gaies,
on parle de la fin,
mais la fin, c'est un sujet
de grande importance
et en effet qui convoque
toutes les dimensions,
politique, médicale,
affective.
On parlait
de solitude, qui est l'un
des grands maux de notre société.
Evoquons plutôt les débuts,
puisque vous avez écrit un livre
qui traite des débuts.
Racontez-nous
quelques débuts joyeux.
-Quelques débuts,
c'est la naissance, par exemple.
C'est le début de quelque chose
qui sera à la fois très joyeux
et très...
-Douloureux aussi.
-Douloureux.
Epuisant.
Mais ce qui m'a intéressée
dans cette question des débuts,
c'est l'intensité.
Il me semble que,
si on a la nostalgie des débuts,
c'est parce qu'il y a
quelque chose dans l'intensité
du sentiment de vivre,
qui est quelque chose
qui nous ranime.
C'est le retour d'un élan.
C'est une forme de ponctuation
ou de rythme de l'existence.
Donc quand quelque chose débute,
que ce soit la vie d'un enfant,
une nouvelle relation,
qu'on s'adonne à une nouvelle
activité, quelle qu'elle soit,
il y a quelque chose
de ce retour de l'élan
que je trouve toujours
à la fois émouvant et surprenant,
y compris
quand on pense
que ça n'arrivera plus.
Donc en fait, la question
des débuts, elle croise aussi
des thématiques
qui sont parfois tragiques.
Comment on peut connaître
de nouveaux débuts,
alors qu'on a pu croire
à cause de son âge,
à cause de la catastrophe
qu'on vient de vivre,
que jamais on retrouvera cet élan,
ce désir d'être en vie,
de nouer des liens, ce sentiment
amoureux avec cette intensité.
Donc il y a quelque chose
de toujours un peu miraculeux
dans le fait
de revenir à la vie
quand on a l'impression
d'en être radicalement sorti.
-Merci, Claire Marin,
pour ces derniers mots
qui donnent de l'espoir.
-Merci.
SOUS-TITRAGE :
RED BEE MEDIA
...